all right instill the 2020 election is
happening you wrote today about former
Vice President Joe Biden likely to be
the candidate but what sort of strategy
will he deploy in all of this and the
idea that he would call Trump to try to
make some sort of deal or agreement is
there any appetite for that right now
well I thought it was interesting the
president was asked would he take a call
from Biden and he said yes and Biden's
people immediately said we're gonna try
and set up such a call I thought it was
interesting though Biden's campaign
response to it this is what his
spokesman said about this call to the
president president been slow and
chaotic in his response he spent months
disregarding repeated warnings from his
health and science advisors I'd like to
hear what dr. fowey has to say about
that he could have heeded by this public
advise not to take the Chinese at their
word well wasn't it Vice President Biden
didn't he call the ban on China travel
racist and and hyper as hypersensitive
and the next one was murdered more cases
than we have more cases than any other
country in the world well wait a minute
that's taking China at its word we have
more cases than China but the but that's
the official number the unofficial
number may be as many as ten times as
the 85,000 that they claim the cases
that they've had so I mean this is it
not a good way to sort of set it up it
was like president made a good-faith to
effort up sure I'll be too happy to take
his call and the immediate response to
the Biden campaign was the kind of
shrill hyper partisanship that is what
the country doesn't want right now right
now the country wants unity and less
partisanship and that comment from the
Biden campaign I think was particularly
tone-deaf as many of his comments in
recent days have been the accusations
that he's been throwing that have been
wild the declarations that he you know
the president Trump oughta listen to
doctor foul Qi and an ambassador birx
and and that's just after we've seen the
president standing alongside them in a
briefing in which he's been sharing with
the American people how he's taking
their advice and acting on it it just is
a bad bad bad handling out